ohne Russen Gas gehen dann bei uns in
Deutschland möglicherweise schon in
diesem Herbst in diesem Winter die
Lichter aus und es wird wahrscheinlich
ein Stromausfall geben dass die das
Speichern gefüllt sind das hat gar
nichts das können ja die Leitungen
unterbrochen werden heute ist die zweite
Alarmstufe beim Plan für Gas
ausgesprochen worden duschen ist die
neue Freiheit ich hätte das auch niemals
gedacht dass ich beim morgen nicht
duschen an Freiheit denken würde im
Winter brauchen wir die Kernkraft zurück
wenn Putins Gas und Öl dann weg sind was
wir hier sehen das erinnert mich an
Ländern in denen die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität lange nicht so ist wie in
Deutschland und ich höre jeden Tag und
lese jeden Tag die Angst der Menschen
wie verzweifelt sie sind dass sie nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Energiekosten
bezahlen kann dass sie Angst davor haben
ein
Blackout könnte eintreten
[Musik]
gerade hier in Deutschland Energiepreis
Alarm im ganzen Land und unser Eindruck
ist die Regierung hat das noch gar nicht
richtig verstanden die kümmert sich noch
gar nicht darum die Energiepreise die
Rasen rauf wie seit Jahren nicht mehr
und jetzt Millionen Deutsche sind
deswegen aktuell in Sorge ob sie im
Winter überhaupt ein Gasanbieter haben
und ich will trotzdem zwei nicht und
verknappe Energie oder ich
beschleunige den Kohleausstieg noch mehr
und wir sind angewiesen auch auf
Energieimporte aus dem Ausland und die
uns dann unseren Preis diktieren können
das ist
das hängt sehr stark jetzt von Russland
selbst ab und vom Verhalten Russlands
wie unser generelles Verhältnis
zueinander ist Deutschland Europäische
Union zu Russland aber eben auch wie es
mit nostream 2 weitergeht ich finde es
gibt keine wirtschaftliche Frage die am
Ende wichtige wichtiger sein kann als
Außen- und sicherheitspolitische
Interessen Deutschlands und Europas da
gibt es für mich eine ganz andere in der
CD positionieren sich ja klar Akku in
Gedanken eben zu Ende machen in dieser
Frage bitte es gibt am Ende keine
wirtschaftspolitische Frage die
wichtiger ist als unsere Außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen Interessen das
ist für mich sehr sehr klar da geht es
um viel in allen Bereichen vor allem
aber auch für Händler Waldi ist es ja
auch nicht das erste Mal dass es zu
solchen Situationen kommt im übrigen
auch ganz anders Ukraine und und andere
schwierige Situationen die wir in den
letzten Jahren gesehen haben und am Ende
liegt es tatsächlich an Russland
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
heute ist ein furchtbarer Tag für die
Ukraine
Explosionen über der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt Kiew Schüsse und Rauch über
der Millionenstadt parkgift der Krieg in
der Ukraine hat begonnen das bizarre an
der sitzsituation ist bezahlen tun wir
das wenn wir bei uns tanken fahren wenn
wir in Bayern bei Bayern Öl Sprit tanken
oder mit der Gastherme heizen wenn wir
wenn wir kochen zahlen wir demnächst den
Preis für diesen Krieg Putin verdient
sich daran eine goldene Nase einfach
weil jetzt die Ölpreise hochgehen die
Gaspreise hochgehen bei uns sind die
Gasspeicher leer wir haben zugelassen
dass die Gasspeicher bei uns seinen
Konzern gehören dass die größten
Gasspeicher Deutschlands in
Niedersachsen sind dass die Gazprom
gehören und wir zahlen
55% des Erdgases in Deutschland kommt
von Gazprom muss man sagen die
Bundesregierung hat gestern gesagt
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck dass
die Reserven auch wenn die Erdgas
Lieferung aus Russland jetzt sozusagen
im Gegenzug zu Sanktionen gekappt werden
würden die Reserven noch für diesen
erreichen würde weil man sich Flüssiggas
von woanders besorgen könnte das ist
danach aber dann auch knapp werden
können ja und es mag ja reichen aber das
was da ist wird der teurer einfach weil
die weil die Preise steigen und das ist
das bizarre wir bezahlen putinskrieg
Nord Stream 1 liefert nur noch 20% Gas
der russische Konzern Gazprom senkt die
Lieferungen durch die Ostsee-Pipeline
Nord Stream eins weiter Putin nutzt die
Mittel die er hat das ist ja keine neue
Situation und auch in keinster Weise
überraschend seit Anfang des Jahres ist
dieses Szenario eine ernste Bedrohung
wir sind darauf vorbereitet aber es ist
natürlich eine ernste Situation also
wenn jetzt irgendjemand überrascht ist
und sagt oh wir sind abhängig von
russischem Gas und Putin könnte es
einsetzen dann hat er das haben die
Leute dann das letzte halbe Jahr gemacht
wir müssen die gasverbräuche
runterbringen wir haben eine
gasknappheit die erfolgt eine
Stromknappheit
die Preise fliegen uns um die Ohren
dreifach fünffache Preise aber viel
entscheidender ist ja was eben der
Wirtschaftsminister nicht thematisiert
ist dass über 50 Prozent des Gases in
die Industrie und des Gewerbe geht das
geht eben in die Metallverarbeitung das
geht in die Chemie das geht in die BASF
das geht in die brötchenbäckerei
ganz wichtig man muss zunächst mal
klarstellen der Blackout ist kein
Stromausfall sondern hat ganz andere
auslösende Ursachen nämlich die großen
Kraftwerke trennen sich vom Stromnetz
und dadurch wird eben das Stromnetz
komplett vom Strom befreit wenn man so
möchte und damit funktioniert rein gar
nichts mehr und bei einem Blackout
müssen wir damit rechnen dass es
mindestens mal Deutschland betrifft
vielleicht sogar ganz Europa und die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist meiner Meinung
nach bei 99,9%
die Energiekonzerne wollen uns noch mehr
aus der Tasche ziehen und das wohl schon
ab Oktober der Staat macht es möglich
eine geplante gasumlage kostet die
Verbraucher ab Oktober hunderte Euros
zusätzlich zu den ohnehin schon
ordentlich gestiegenen Gaspreisen
gasdeckel halt eben machen das ist auch
so ein Grundbedarf ist einfach für alle
gleich und das in England gemacht ist
unser Gehalt wird ja sonst aufgebraucht
für Strom Gas so dass sich der normale
sozusagen nichts mehr zu essen kaufen
kann das ist auf den Punkt gebracht und
dann bricht ja auch die ganze Wirtschaft
dann zusammen ich finde es bisschen
ungerecht dass wir für unser Geld
arbeiten und dann suche Preise zahlen
müssen und
das ist sehr kritisch wir haben unser
Leben lang für unsere Renten gearbeitet
genauso meine Tochter mein Schwiegersohn
Zahlen schön ihre Steuern gehen aber
immer leer aus und das finde ich
ungerecht ich persönlich höre diese
Angst und dieser Verzweiflung und dann
sehe ich eine Politik die in Haufen
Scheiße erzählt die Almosen verteilt wir
brauchen einen gasdeckel der für alle
wirklich wirkt
diese Umlage ist die gerechtmöglichste
Form die zusätzlich aufgelaufenen Kosten
in der Bevölkerung zu verteilen und zu
tragen die Alternative ist nicht keine
Umlage die Alternative wäre der
Zusammenbruch des deutschen
Energiemarktes gewesen und damit weite
Teile des europäischen Energiemarktes
wir müssen jetzt Panik haben damit zu
unserem Herbst nicht so schlechter geht
und ich sage Ihnen wir haben noch nicht
genug das ist aber wir wollen Paniker
ich habe vorhin gesagt wir haben in
diesem mai 2022 so viel Gas verbrannt
für Stromausfall wie noch nie in der
Geschichte Deutschlands dass ich in der
Sache
hinein ist natürlich auch ein Blackout
nicht ausgeschlossen dass er 99,9%
wahrscheinlich ist halte ich für Unsinn
sich nach Möglichkeit vorzubereiten kann
nie schaden ja also auch an vernünftigen
wasservorratsraum ich bin selber vor
zehn Jahren
verbraucherschutzsenator geworden da
haben wir eine Übung gemacht das in
Berlin vier Tage lang der Strom nicht
geht was passiert wenn beispielsweise in
der Hauptstadt die Lichter ausgehen in
Berlin wenn Tankstellen und Supermärkte
schließen und Heizungen ausfallen weil
der Strom abgeschaltet ist kommt es dann
zu Unruhen zu plünder rein
was nach Panikmache klingt ist ein ganz
konkretes Szenario auf das die Berliner
Polizei sich hinter den Kulissen
vorbereitet im Papier geht die Polizei
von einem partiellen Ausfall der
Energieversorgung aus doch wenn der
sogenannte Blackout da ist sei mit
Plünderungen Unruhen und Angriffen auf
die kritische Infrastruktur zu rechnen
nach Einschätzung der Experten könnte es
in den kommenden Monaten tatsächlich
dazu kommen Energien wie Strom und Gas
werden rationiert passiert ganz was
anderes die Kraftwerke schalten sich aus
zum Eigenschutz vom Netz weg und das
bedeutet nichts hat mehr Strom und das
bedeutet auch nichts tut es mehr und das
ist halt das Riesenproblem weil erstens
mal haben wir kaum noch schwarz statt
fähige Kraftwerke also Kraftwerke die
aus eigener Kraft wieder dann hochfahren
können dass das eine Problem und das
zweite ist alle Datendienste alles was
mit Computer mit Internet und so zu tun
hat ist auch weg und wir haben gasmangel
wir haben die größte Dürre seit 500
Jahren
mit der Dürre ist sowohl die Steinkohle
betroffen die Wasserkraft ist in Europa
maximal niedrig und die französischen
Atomkraftwerke sind in sanierungspausen
diese diese gleichzeitige Menge hat das
Stromnetz natürlich
weniger stabil gemacht und deswegen
müsste es mehr riedispatch-maßnahmen
geben das Risiko ist eindeutig gestiegen
weil die Umgebungsfaktoren viel
schlechter geworden sind
aber dass das jetzt zu 99,9% passiert
ist Unsinn es gibt eine ganze Industrie
die daran arbeitet das ist nicht
passiert und dafür muss auch gut bezahlt
wird belügt Robert Habeck also die
Bürger er sagt uns nicht die ganze
Wahrheit die Wirtschaftsweisen der
Sachverständigenrat für Wirtschaft hat
gesagt lassen Sie bitte die
Kernkraftwerke am Netz die
Energieversorger haben es gibt also die
Netzbetreiber haben gesagt das ist alles
viel zu riskant wir können für nicht für
jede Stunde garantieren das genügend
Strom da ist wir spielen hier mit der
Lebensadern unserer Nation und nur wegen
Parteipolitik nur weil er tritt ihn
gesagt hat wenn ihr das macht trete ich
aus der Partei aus das interessiert mich
nicht und deswegen ist Harbeck
Gefangener seine eigenen Ideologie und
zusammen mit der Umweltministerin hat
erst doch schon über Monate verschluckt
ist doch immer weiter Kapazität da und
es wurde gar nicht viel bringen dann
belügt er doch eigentlich die Bürger ja
natürlich er erzählt uns nicht die
Wahrheit und
hat natürlich ein Modell vor Augen das
bedeutet ja es wird keinen kalten Winter
geben ja das können sich alles schön
rechnen
Kernkraft in Frankreich sind Überfluss
da ja also das lässt einen fassungslos
zurück vor allem haben wir alle noch im
Ohr glaube ich und es war wieder einmal
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister und viele
seiner grünen Parteifreunde die doch
eigentlich uns die ganze Zeit erzählt
haben wir hätten gar keinen Stromproblem
das ist ja wirklich ganz bemerkenswert
interessant offenbar haben wir doch eins
und umso bemerkenswerter ist weiterhin
das Robert Habeck beispielsweise die bei
Kernkraftwerke auch unbedingt abschalten
möchte zum Jahreswechsel was das
Stromproblem eher größer denn kleiner
machen würde wer hat die beiden
ostsee-pipelines in die Luft gejagt wer
ist für diesen Gas leckt Villa
verantwortlich am Montag kommt es in
beiden Pipelines nordstream 1 und Nord
Stream 2 zu starken druckabfällen die
Ursache insgesamt Dreiecks in den
Pipeline zwei Explosionen die am Montag
in Schweden und Dänemark an mehreren
Messstationen registriert wurden
sprechen gegen einen Unfall das hier ist
ein klarer sabotageaktt das sollte jetzt
wirklich jedem klar sein und Scholz
behauptet er habe immer vorausgesehen
dass Putin sein Gas als Waffe nutzen
würde das gleiche gilt wenn wir über die
Frage diskutieren was ist mit den
Energielieferungen denn auch die nutzt
der russische Präsident als Waffe
ich war mir immer sicher dass er das tun
würde habe ich mir schon im Dezember die
Frage gestellt und sie weitergegeben an
alle meine Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiter
was passiert eigentlich wenn Russland
kein Gast mehr liefert noch im dezember
2021 zwei Monate vor dem Krieg sagte der
Kanzler die Pipeline habe mit der Lage
in der Ukraine nicht zu tun es handelt
sich im Hinblick auf Nord Stream 2 um
ein privatwirtschaftliches Vorhaben so
Scholz damals kurz danach besuchte er
Putin allerdings nur warum hat er dann
nichts getan ja es gibt ja nur zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder er hat vorher
gewusst und uns bewusst verschwiegen und
dann uns weiter von Russland mit
abhängig gemacht oder er wusste es
damals nicht und tut heute so als habe
es gewusst ich weiß nicht was schlimmer
ist von beiden Möglichkeiten es besteht
da in jedem Fall dringender
Aufklärungsbedarf also zunächst einmal
muss vollkommen klar sein es geht um
Deutschland und es geht um die Menschen
in unserem Land und dafür fast alles zu
tun und es geht nicht um Grüne Partei
Befindlichkeiten das kann nicht im
Mittelpunkt unserer Sorge stehen
deswegen ist es vernünftig in dieser
Situation alles auf den Markt zu werfen
was geht dazu gehört Biomasse dazu
gehört vieles andere dazu gehört aber
eben auch Kernenergie es ist die
Nachricht des Abends Olaf Scholz hat auf
den Tisch gehauen und ein Machtwort
gesprochen das ist meine Prognose
spätestens Anfang des nächsten Jahres
erneut darüber unterhalten wie es denn
nun weitergeht denn klar ist wir
brauchen zur Stromerzeugung derzeit auch
viel Gas wir wissen aber Gas ist knapp
und wir wissen auch dass die
Kernkraftwerke zur Zeit zur
Stromproduktion ungefähr sieben bis acht
Prozent beitragen was liefert direkt mal
die Tipps mit man sollte Bargeld im Haus
haben Essen 14 Tage und zwei Liter
Flüssigkeit pro Person pro Tag den
Bürger wird also auch noch erklärt wie
man eigentlich am besten ein Vorrat
aufbaut als könnte er das nicht ich
frage mich wie kommt man auf solche
Infantin Vorschläge und warum ver die
Politik derartige Blackout Panik fakt
ist gemessen an den Füllständen unserer
Gasspeicher können wir vorerst halbwegs
entspannt in den Winter gehen am
Dienstag teilte die Bundesnetzagentur
erst mit dass die aktuellen Füllstände
bei 92% liegen damit sind wir im sollen
die Gasversorgung ist also in
Deutschland aktuell
[Musik]